[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
hello i'm nicholas thompson i'm the
editor-in-chief of wired
you may have seen me in that video just
a second ago with much
shorter hair i haven't cut my hair since
quarantine began and
here we are but thank you for being here
thank you for joining us at this year's
wired 25
and watching that video it makes me
nostalgic
for the last two years commonwealth club
sf jazz sitting right next to people
touching the little robots running
on the embarcadero it was amazing
but i'm glad we are here i'm glad we get
to do this and i'm glad we get to do
this
at such an important time at a moment
where we're
dealing with so many crisis where we
have the pandemic
where we're sorting through election
questions of trust but we had a long
overdue recommend
over racial justice where there are
fires and it is moments
moments like this where it feels
particularly important
to have an event like wire25 because the
point of wire25
is to start conversations and meet
people who are using
the awesome powers of tech and the
incredible powers of science
to make the world better to take a look
at these problems
and to try to use tech to solve them
that's what we do
at wire25 where we start conversations
on these stages
we continue them on our website and it
is at
dark moments like this where it feels
particularly necessary
so i'm glad you're here and i want to
thank our sponsors samsung
and vonage who by supporting this event
have made it free
for everyone online i guess the one good
thing about it being online is it makes
it a lot easier to book people from
all over the place because they don't
have to travel so this year we have
speakers from
france germany israel mexico the
philippines
scotland and taiwan all across the
united states as well we have san
francisco boston seattle la dc brooklyn
the bronx santa cruz palo alto
and hammond louisiana the youngest is 17
the oldest is 79. and so for the next
two weeks starting today
and then the next two wednesdays we're
gonna talk
about all these pressing
complicated issues but issues where
technology science people with ideas
can actually bring us forward
tonight we're going to specialize focus
on cultural innovators
and artists we have an incredible lineup
people doing extraordinary things we
impressed with every single conversation
and i am of course very excited for the
first one
which is with reed hastings ceo of
netflix
i first interviewed him 17 years ago i
was writing a story i was a young
reporter i was writing the story for the
new york times
and the question animating the story was
whether this new startup with the little
fin red envelopes could defeat the
challenge of blockbuster
and walmart and turns out they they did
pretty well
they've they've done all right and in
fact it's only been
seven years since they launched their
first original series house of cards and
they're heading into this weekend's
emmys with
160 nominations shows like ozark the
crown
stranger things they have deals with
incredible super producers ryan murphy
barack michelle obama prince harry
meghan markle
obviously this company does them pretty
well i've done a lot of interesting
cultural things since i first wrote
about them
way back when so how did this all happen
what is reid hastings
secret for running the company he has
just published a book
which i have read i'm going to ask him a
whole bunch of questions about it
so let's get started
hello i'm back and i'm here with reed
hastings
reed is the co-founder chairman and
co-ceo of
netflix he's also the co-author of no
rules rules
a riveting new book that i have just
completed
you have probably spent more time
perhaps indirectly with
reid than anybody else except your
immediate family since march
so welcome reid hastings how are you
welcome to wired25
we are so thrilled to provide
entertainment for all that time and to
give people
a little escape and after working for
three years on this book it's gonna be
fun to talk about
it's gonna be great to talk about so
reid we i read through your book it's
got
lots of wonderful stuff about culture
about dynamics about how you build
netflix about
how you manage people why 25 is mostly
about how
technology improves the world how it
makes us live more fulfilled lives i
want you to talk a little bit about
the reason for netflix the moral purpose
of netflix
and how the culture of netflix affects
it
so let's see the the book no rules rules
is really about
keeping a culture innovative as you grow
so i think that's the the big tie-in for
your theme is
um most companies have a burst of
innovation that the startup phase
and then there's a phase of harvest and
then they're
rarely able to continue to innovate and
that was also true of my first company
pure software
so what we're doing in netflix
is trying to show if you set aside the
rules
if you really focus on the people over
process
um that you can continue to innovate at
a great place
at a great pace and have an incredibly
creative environment that's fun and
satisfying
to think about netflix uh independent of
that culture for zach you asked about
the purpose our purpose is to entertain
the world
to provide people around the world the
most phenomenal entertainment service
they've ever seen
and we do that by producing all over the
world so we produce
in spain in germany in japan and korea
in the uk
and brazil of course a lot in the us
so think of it as we want to produce
content everywhere and
share that around the world and some of
the
most fantastic stories come from other
places
and really what that helps do
is connect people so if you're a
globalist
like i am you want to knit the world
together
and you want people to understand
respect love and appreciate each other
and entertainment is a key part of how
that happens
and so we are so excited when we have a
a hit that people all around the world
are enjoying together
that's a really interesting and
important idea particularly in 2020 as
the politics of the world become more
nationalist and particularly as the tech
sector splits right as we
split into a western tech sphere and an
eastern text here
do the current dynamics of global
politics make this
mission of yours more prevalent and does
it change the way you think of specific
types of content that cross-borders know
i have to stop you it's not really
splitting eastern and western
head-splitting chinese and non-chinese i
mean
india korea japan are all i was trying
to be
generous about it but yes i mean i mean
there's a very specific
uh tragic you know separation of china
from the rest of the internet
um but the whole rest of the world is
possible for netflix to i believe
they've got this great story out of uh
korea
uh crash landing on you and you know
it's this romantic comedy but
it involves north korea and north korea
so like the tensest border in the world
and then here's this romantic comedy
between south koreans and north koreans
um or uh a film we have out of japan
sorry siri is naked director
that's about sexual expression in japan
which is a relatively
uh repressed place so um whether it's
the east whether it's the west
you know it's really about storytelling
for us
tell me about how your culture
has transitioned as you become more of a
global company because you say that
maintaining culture gets harder as a
company
gets larger and as it spreads across the
globe so you created a culture in
silicon valley
for silicon valley people and it is now
a culture for a massively global company
whose moral purpose is global in certain
ways explain that tension
you know uh early days we were dvd
shippers
and mostly in silicon valley and
my co-ceo ted sarandos would travel from
la up to silicon valley every week
and then about 10 years ago we pivoted
to really become an entertainment
company with
a house of cards orange is the new black
and now i commute to la every week for a
couple days
okay so it's we're really much more uh
l.a centric
and we used to have worries about you
know silicon valley versus hollywood and
those cultural tensions
and the great thing about going
international is then
you know our brazilian and german
colleagues would laugh at us and say you
know you're all californians you are so
profoundly american
and there's no real difference in the
big difference is between you know the
californians
and uh the dutch and the french
you know we've worked really hard to
build community between
uh our different employee groups and
connection and i think we've done a good
job of that
you know a particular example uh is in
feedback
so us cultures tend to be very direct
very verbal and japanese cultures
because they're very sophisticated tend
to be able to communicate
indirectly very well they call it
reading the air
and if you're too if we're both japanese
i can say i'm unhappy with this activity
but i never have to say it verbally
my cues are so precise and well tuned
that i'm confident you got the message
even without the words now of course
cross-culturally when americans are
involved in that it doesn't really work
that well we don't you know
understand the air we misinterpret why
didn't they say what they meant
all those kinds of misunderstandings and
just as we use
english as a standard language around
the world it's no better or worse than
other languages but it is very
functional
um we've adopted the american more
verbal feedback style
and our japanese colleagues have been
willing to adapt to that when dealing
with non-japanese
so that's a case where the the
california style is sort of the
the global style for us now another
example
is americans build trust um through
doing tasks together
so we would be like some project okay
and we don't like the chit chat we see
that as kind of inefficient and
let's get to the point you know we're
very efficient focused
and brazilians are very relationship
oriented so they want to go and
have dinner and like not talk about work
exactly talk about family and sports and
religion
and society and form a relationship and
get to know each other and then they
work in the office very effectively
and we realized wow the brazilian
approach
actually works better because you've got
deeper relationships and it allows
feedback to be much more trusting
and helpful so it's the combination of
the brazilian
relationship style combined with later
the direct feedback that has been really
effective for us and so we've
you know really promoted the brazilian
style relationship investment
and we do a lot throughout the company
to invest in relationships
um not talking about core business
issues
so that's an example again where the
brazilian style seems to be the best
and and we've standardized on that
globally so it sounds like what you're
saying is that there's a core netflix
culture that is
adapted and shifted a little bit as you
move into different countries
the core netflix culture is pretty
intense right constant feedback as you
said
you know you have this famous line that
adequate performance gets a generous
severance package
right people should constantly be
checking whether everybody who works for
them
is the very best and if they would fight
to keep them if they got a competitor
that's that's tough stuff and is that
why
you say fantastic stuff because you get
to work with
incredible colleagues look we're more
honest about it but we're not like the
first company to think about that
it's just we're super direct about it
and we say
look the traditional model for a company
is a family
and in a family you know you stick with
your brother no matter how dysfunctional
okay and the other model
is a sports team okay a professional
football team
and with that it is high performance
you're never going to win a championship
unless you've got great players in every
position
and so we model ourselves on how does a
t a professional team work and they care
about each other
uh they're very close the only
difference of course is netflix is not
fixed 11 people
you know as we get more great people we
get to grow and that's a big difference
so
you don't have people competing you know
for the only tight end position
you know that's there so uh but again
that's the family versus team but i
think the big difference is that
netflix we're very honest about who we
are and what we're trying to be
and for people who value
peer excellence and they value learning
were incredible four people who
primarily value job security
um that were not a great match and
there's no judgment in that and
and people will select out and and you
know go to a different firm
so i very much related to this in fact
directly related to something you said i
want to read you my favorite sentence
in the entire book which i enjoyed
beginning to end
one of the things i was interested as i
was reading it is how you would
compare your culture where everybody's
evaluating employees constantly to the
old microsoft culture of stack rankings
and in fact you address it directly
and there's an employee and he's an
engineer and he was quite successful as
an engineer and then he moved into more
of a
role where he had to talk to people as
part of user testing
and that was uncomfortable and he asked
his manager his manager said he wasn't
good at it so he trained and this is
what he wrote
the day of my first netflix presentation
i got up at six am
unicycled for four hours took a shower
and walked directly into the meeting
room for my 11 a.m presentation and it's
a good story
about both the kind of person who works
at netflix he's unicycling for four
hours
and the pressure to perform and to
respond
to feedback so tell me a little bit more
about whether there were lessons you
learned from other silicon valley
companies that had stank ranking stack
rankings
in competitive systems and how you
managed that jack welch from ge
pioneered it and he said managers don't
like to get rid of people
so i have to force them to by having
every manager has to fire 10
of the people every year and that's an
incredibly crude and destructive
approach because what you do is you
don't want to help
your colleagues because then they'll be
potentially above you
um you know because you're graded on
this curve where ten percent of the
people are forced out
so i i think that's horrific um and
microsoft stack ranking which they've
now gotten rid of
has some of the same dynamic it didn't
include you know the bottom 10 percent
gets fired but
you know it was uh it's fixed ratios
so we want a manager to hire all great
people so they have no one
you know who's not performing and to do
that
we ask them to just supply the keeper
test
and it's the manager's judgment they may
say i would
absolutely keep this person they're not
that good at this function but at these
they're incredible
but it's manager judgment we're
definitely a company to
lean into judgment i know we're thought
of as data and silicon valley's about
data
and we do use data for some things like
consumer testing on the service of what
features work better
but we're also very embracing of human
judgment
and of refining that judgment including
um
you know how to help our people do well
right
let's talk a little bit about data for a
second because it's a topic of netflix
that has always interested me i edited a
story at wired maybe
13 years ago about i can't remember the
guy's name but it was like just a guy in
a garage he was zooming up the netflix
challenge created a new algorithm for
recommendations and beating all you know
the teams from mit it's a wonderful
story
tell me how the recommendation algorithm
which is core to netflix has
evolved over time both in the inputs it
considers
and in the outputs it wants to achieve
well the whole field has evolved
quite a lot with deep learning and
that's become the primary set of
techniques all the techniques of that
very fun uh netflix contest you know 13
years ago
are not in use at netflix or at other
firms so
many big advances in deep learning have
propelled
us and the whole field forward and we're
constantly trying to figure out
how do we provide you a set of great
choices and learn
what new things you might be interested
in you know suppose you took a recent
trip to korea
and we don't know that of course um and
so every now and then we want to put a
korean drama in front of you as a
recommendation to see
are you interested in you know expanding
into these new areas of content
and um so sometimes when you get a bad
recommendation that's actually
us trying to probe the edge to sort of
see what new things might you be
interested in
you literally don't know if someone took
a trip to korea you're not buying
data geolocation data or facebook login
data or data from across other platforms
you're only using first party data
so this be totally clear we we have but
we buy no data
we don't sell any data we're a complete
isolated data island
it's just uh what preferences you have
had what shows
your account has watched compared with
other anonymous accounts at netflix
but let's let's take the korea example
just because privacy is such an
important conversation right now
i travel to korea i log into netflix
while i'm in korea and i watch an
american film presumably you see the
korean
ip address you then factor it into my
recommendations and give me korean films
as a potential record
potentially good idea but uh no till i
know if we don't do that yet
you know there's not enough uh
international travel uh except
a very very narrow group of people but
the point is that we really want
uh to to get you beyond you know
what you nobody wants a film just like
the one you watched last night
okay so the one you watched last night
was great
um you know uh but then you wanna
find you know uh something else that's
you know different
we want something that's fresh yeah
let's let's stick with the data question
for a second because it leads to one of
the things that i've wondered a lot
about netflix in the last year which is
that if you look at the
tech backlash the backlash that's been
since 2016 it's you know it's hit
a lot of your peer companies it hit
facebook hard while you were on the
board it hit
google a certain degree it hit microsoft
like
some strange degree it's even hit tesla
but it hasn't hit
netflix and is that because you're not
really a tech company you're not a
platform obviously you're disruptive and
you use tech is there
a difference there is it because you're
not
in the you're not influencing american
democracy you're just influencing
american culture
explain why the tech backlash hasn't
come for you yet
well one we don't have advertising and
once you have advertising you're
incented to import lots of data and
learn everything you can
and around not just entertainment taste
but a broad range of things so
fundamentally from the business
model we have a much simpler business
model which is you know
uh thank you for your 15 a month and
then provide you great entertainment
and second we're fundamentally an la
company
um you know that does incredible tech uh
and our biggest competitors are disney
plus and hbo max
okay so you know our competitive set
our core um two-thirds of our spending
is on content you know
out of la um so uh
you know we're not um again really in
the core
of the you know google facebook uh tech
orientation
or even culture and when you talk about
netflix culture sometimes you put in a
historical context and you say that most
companies
were organized based on a factory model
and netflix is organized differently
and what interests me when i hear you
talk about that is it suggests that
at some point society will evolve in a
way that your model will become obsolete
or that you'll have to really evolve
your model that will no longer be right
right if other companies are using an
out of date model then at some point you
will
how will you know when that moment comes
well
think of ea or pixar as other companies
that are doing both
tech and entertainment and using tech
for
great entertainment and so we're like
that
for series and films and when we look at
the future and say
someday series and films may be like the
novel
or the opera sort of a very small art
form
what are the things that might
out-compete movies and series
so one would be user generated content
like youtube or tick tock
another might be new hardware assisted
ai
ar you know scenarios another might be
video gaming so these are all
potential substitution threats and
we know how to compete directly against
hbo max and disney plus
and uh you know and and that's great and
hard and interesting and fun
and then there's the substitution
threats where you know getting into
their business is not a good way to
compete with it because we won't be as
good
you know at them but for now movies and
series seem very strong
seem like a core human format remember
that you know movies have been around
for over a hundred years
uh continue to grow uh tv series for 50
years 60 years now and continue to grow
so you know i think we're on to a pretty
long-term thing but at least in
principle
someday uh movies and tv shows
you know will be small right all right
well we're almost out of time and so
will you please give a recommendation to
everybody here at wire25 on
what they should watch and will you also
please tell us what's coming next from
the obamas and harry and meg
last night i watched a film uh wildlife
with jake gyllenhaal that i thought was
extraordinary it's my kind of film
it's slow um and beautiful in montana
so if you like art films uh discover
wildlife
uh and then uh obama's and harry and
megan are producers
that are doing a wide range of content
they're able to attract
amazing storytellers for us and
uh look forward to their content along
with
all of our other incredible producers
all right well i'm glad you ended on
montana because the first time i ever
interviewed you
i called you from a pay phone and you
listened to national park in montana
to fact check something so thank you
very much reid hastings thank you
everybody for
tuning in this part of wire25 see you in
a second
hi hello everybody welcome to our panel
innovating through design my name is
irene al i am design partner at coastal
ventures
thanks for joining us today on the panel
are celia hodand she is a freelance game
ux strategist and former director of
user experience at epic games which
creates fortnite
and then we also have drew blackard who
is vp of mobile product management at
samsung
so thank you for joining us um and
we'll start the panel with celia
you are a psychologist by training and
you hold a phd in the field
um not many people recognize that quite
a few designers are actually
psychologists
i imagine your background in psychology
was valuable in helping you get inside
the head of a gamer
and use those insights to make fortnite
a compelling and successful game
um so can you share some of your uh
understandings of gamers brains and
what that meant for game design while
you were fortnite
sure i can try it so the brain is a bit
complex
but um experiencing a video game just
like anything that you experience
happens in your mind and so we need to
understand a little bit how people
process information and learn about
something
and we know that the the brain has great
uh performances but we also have great
limitations like for example when you
learn about something or you process
information from around you it starts
from your senses
so all the senses that we have we have
way more than five
um is gathering all the information from
the environment and then we're gonna
process that information um the problem
is that what
one of the big limitations of perception
is that it's subjective
we don't all perceive the world as it is
there is
one world a reality and we all perceive
something different
and so when we create a game we have to
understand that perception is subjective
and we have to
take a step back and verify that the the
things that all the
the inputs all the stimuli that we we
have in the in the game that are mostly
visual
and audio are going to be perceived the
way we intended
and then when you learn you have to
memorize a bunch of stuff and we know
that the brain
doesn't is not great at memorizing
things
and we don't memorize uh things very
precisely like if i ask you to remember
um
how is the posture of the thinker the
sculptor from august
most people don't exactly remember you
know i is it like
one hand on on the left leg in which
hand
we don't really remember that and so we
forget a bunch of stuff and what we
remember is not
accurate so we have to take that into
account um because we can't rely on
players memory and playing a video game
is as across
several uh days and and sometimes weeks
and months and so we have to make sure
that players are going to remember the
important information and we give away
information all the time and the last
thing is as
well it's not lasting but among the
examples i want to give is when you
process information you have to pay
attention the more we pay attention to
things
well the the better we re we process
that information and we
remember it and in a video game that
typically there's a lot of information
going on there's a lot of things to
focus on and we want to make sure that
players are not going to be overwhelmed
by too many things
and also that whenever we need to convey
an important information such as
you know how to um learn a new skill how
to use something
how system is working we want to make
sure that players can really focus on it
so
these are just a little bit of some
examples and of course it's a very
complex topic
um about why cognitive science and
cognitive psychology more specifically
is really important so that we can
anticipate
problems and make sure that the players
are going to have the experience that we
want
for them and so we take into account the
mutations of the brain
to do that can you tell us a little bit
more about your
process at epic for developing fortnite
much has been said about design thinking
and systems design
and things like that and maybe you could
walk us through what does a general
process look like and maybe share a
couple of examples that illustrate how
your understanding of users helped you
evolve fortnite sure
um yeah we we use the same design
thinking process like
like in other um industries except that
in
the video game industry i would say it's
much newer than in other industries so
there's still a lot of
things to put in place um but we make
assumptions
and we're gonna test these assumptions
so we make prototypes and we test them
like very
quick and dirty prototypes we we test
them with a few people if it's working
then
we start to implement uh them and then
we re-test and then we
of course the artist is going to add uh
the um artistic layer to
uh make it much more compelling and we
re-test again
and once all the systems are in place
like in the game like fortnite there's a
lot of different systems you need to
build you need to craft you
need to um manage your inventory
there's a lot of stuff going on and once
everything is put together
this is when typically um the the video
game industries
is using a lot of beta tests um today so
we can make sure
of what's going on in the wild um as
compared to plate testing and
when people are coming really and and at
the studio so we can watch what's going
on and if people understand it
and and then we do beta tests and so we
can see in the wild
if if our assumptions are still uh
correct and we can also
um fine-tune all the the stuff that we
can
cannot fine-tune beforehand such as you
know balancing the game making sure that
if you have different
um classes in the game such as uh you
know a constructor
a soldier a ninja making sure that it's
well balanced and that the difficulty is
never too easy or too hard so there's a
lot of things we need to balance and
then that happens
more towards the uh the beta um
test so it's it's very similar to um
the design thinking uh that a classic
design thingy process
um except that the the the objectives
are a bit different
and unlike a tool a video game is as
uh has its uh um it's not a means to an
end
the whole point of playing a video game
is is to take pleasure into interacting
with the system itself so we we need to
take that into account and
not just making sure that the game is
usable but also engaging and fun
so it's it's the same but there's a a
few different things
uh um that we don't have in
the ux of tools or or um
apps in a game we add some challenges
and
these challenges need to be fun
uh well so on this topic of improving
usability and engagement you kind of
point out
how um designing for games has kind of a
different intention in mind because
you're very focused on engagement and
you're
different from a tool uh let's switch
over to drew so first of all drew
congratulations on the launch of the
galaxy z
full 2. um i'm kind of curious to learn
more about
um what did you learn from your users
once you
launched the original fold and how did
that inform and inspire the design of
the full two
yeah the second generation of a product
is always
really exciting to work on because if
you think about it the first generation
is usually
built on an insight really you know just
this idea and with
with fold originally it was about
designing a product that had
the portability of a smartphone that
offered a tablet like experience that
was really the whole idea behind it but
then you put it out into the world and
out of the wild and people use it
and you need to see is it really
resonating in that way is that how
people are actually using it and so
we talked a lot to our fold users over
the past year and
there's a couple really interesting
insights that we're able to
take from them and really inspire the
next generation of the product
the first is around if you think about
just that value proposition altogether
portability yet tablet-like experience
there's always going to be a little bit
of a push and pull there as to
you know what's the right size for a
product like this because on one hand
if the screen's too big it's not really
portable anymore if it's too small
then you don't get the tablet-like
experience and so you know i have one
right here
where we've actually expanded the format
of the display
because 70 of our fold one users said
they wanted even more screen
so what we did is on the exterior
display
it's a 6.2 inch display which is the
same size
as basically our s20 model so you get a
standard uh
smartphone experience on the exterior
and when you open it up
the unfolded experience is 7.6 inches so
it's a full
tablet-like experience when you open it
up and a lot of that was driven around
this idea that users wanted even more
screening
another question we had to address is
well once you've got that larger format
what do you do with it right because you
you want to be able to take advantage of
more screen and what we found
is that our fold users do more of just
about everything so they play more games
they watch more video
but they also do more productivity
applications things like microsoft
office
and their email and things like that so
they do a range of everything
and on top of that we found that they
were seven times more likely to use our
multi-window feature which is
the ability to bring up two apps on the
screen at the same time
and so one of the things that we've done
is we've implemented a feature called
app pairs which allows you to basically
with a single click
launch right into that experience so you
have two apps going at once
this year we're supporting even up to
three applications so
you can really get a lot done it's a
multitasker's dream but a lot of that
was
was driven directly from those insights
of those first generation fold users
wow that's really cool it seems like
you're enabling all kinds of new
user experiences around this form factor
you have twice as many pixels in the
same amount of space that
we had before and um this is new and
improved
um i imagine along with this is there's
a whole ecosystem
around this that you have to develop can
you
kind of share with us how you had to
redesign the software around the fold
and
and the other experiences that are um
related to that so that people can take
full advantage of this new
factor yeah i mean so i mean
the two obvious ones uh i showed you
already right which is when you've got
it as a traditional smartphone and then
more open for the tablet-like experience
where it got really interesting from a
product perspective is what do you do
when it's
in between uh so starting with our
z-flip
uh device earlier in the year we
developed a feature called flex mode
which basically within the hinge system
the device can tell a software
application that the device is
actually folded right now halfway in
between and so it can tell the
application to then orient
itself differently for a use case so
that unlocks a lot of different
types of things you wouldn't be able to
do with just a traditional smartphone so
one that i use a lot is just for video
chat we've worked with google to
optimize the experience so you can have
it hands-free in a tabletop mode while
you have video chat open
and the viewfinder will orient itself
towards the top screen
and the bottom will orient itself
towards the controls of course if you're
doing things like email you'll have the
workspace on top and the keyboard on the
bottom so it's almost like having a mini
little laptop or something to get things
done on
and a range of different applications
are going to do that so that when you
have it
actually physically folded it's going to
bring out even different software
experiences from say the more full
tablet immersive experience or the more
traditional smartphone experience that
it also offers
very cool so a question for both of you
um
was there anything were you surprised by
anything like any
insights or observations from users
as you were developing your respective
products and um
and how might those insights or
surprises change
the course of whatever it was that you
were developing
oh i think i'm sorry um so yeah so
i would say yes and no we're always
surprised by what
users are doing because again we have
our own mental model of what we want to
to create and then
their users and they have their own
objectives and and they perceive things
in in their way so we're always
surprised so this is not surprising
um but there were you know a lot of
things that uh
it can always there's a few examples
here with
fortnite we really care about the
pillars of the game so for example
construction is a big as a strong pillar
so we
gonna you know work a lot on on this to
make it clear for players to make it fun
for players to
to build and they were you know funny
moments where uh
players start to learn how to build and
they want to protect something from
a zombies attacking because you know the
first modern fortnight was saved the
world so was
players versus the environments of
zombies and they were protecting
something by building walls but then
they were walling themselves in and they
were like oh
no what do i do and so they were
destroying one of the wall behind them
to go around to shoot the zombies uh or
just
crafting a a staircase so they could go
above it and then shoot the zombies so
it was it was not clear obviously how to
edit a door
in the walls so is one of these things
that we have to think about
like a shoot as it's not it's not clear
enough and and players are not gonna
have fun if they don't know how to edit
windows or doors in fortnight so it's
that sort of things when you're like oh
no
yeah for us i think an interesting one
was around that flex mode that we just
talked about
on our z flip from earlier in the year
when we launched it we found that people
were actually using
the camera functionality within the flex
mode which was
kind of a surprise to us we didn't
anticipate as much usage around that and
so
we started looking into were there more
ways that we could use the camera
again within that folded form factor so
a couple that we came up with
for fold two that are going to be really
interesting the first is what we call
rear cam selfies so because you can open
the device and have a
full viewfinder on the back it allows
you to use the full triple camera system
for any selfies you're taking so
you know that gives you access to all
the pro
video and pro camera features that we
have so a much
more high-end camera system to take
selfie shots and things like that so it
makes it super easy where traditionally
you're just gonna use the front-facing
camera which is usually not
as high performance of a camera and so
that's one area and then another
uh that's interesting for more say a
content creator
again back into that hands-free mode you
can actually just set
the the device on a tabletop like this
and if you had known around to capture
this might be
for someone who's into posting videos on
youtube or instagram
you can prop it up like that and the
camera using software and artificial
intelligence
has what we call auto framing so it'll
keep the subject in the center of the
frame no matter what you're doing
it'll actually zoom in and out and
follow the subject within
a certain boundary and so that allows
you to basically
have like a cameraman behind the phone
but shooting it all by yourself
um and again a lot of those are driven
by the fact that it's such a unique
form factor that there's cool and new
interesting things that we can do with
it a lot of that was just driven from
that
surprise finding that the camera was
really a way people
wanted to engage with that new form
factor
that's very cool i can't wait to get my
handle on one of these
um so in this discussion we've kind of
explored how
the whole field of design draws upon an
understanding of
people like user perception and
cognition
to make technology work for people like
make technology work for people the way
they like to work and think
we have also witnessed how some
companies can use this understanding
to manipulate users where engagement
turns into addiction
and technology takes over our attention
i want to hear your respective thoughts
on this and how do you try to strike a
balance
if at all
now jurgen start now yeah
i'll take this one yeah i think there's
um
a lot of tools that we can put in place
to really help users
gauge how they want to engage with their
own kind of products and environments
and services and so
a couple that come to mind for me are
you know first is around
just screen time right people are
concerned around the more time they're
they're spending uh you know with their
with their smartphones that it could
disrupt sleep patterns things like that
so
in all of our products full two included
we have
a built-in blue light filter that you
can automate and kind of customize
depending on how you use your own device
and throughout the day things like that
we also support a full suite of
digital well-being features that are
part of the android ecosystem
and so those allow you to measure things
like
screen time and even app time and and if
you want to kind of
self-monitor those it has the tools
there to do it
um and then i also think more broadly
beyond just phones of course you know
samsung provides a broad ecosystem
of products and so our wearables for
example are a great way
they're cellularly connected so if you
wanted to leave the house for a few
hours and just tune out
leave your your phone at home um you can
have
that that connection just in case you
know for emergencies but have the peace
of mind of not having to look at a
screen
as you're out and about and things like
that so we're trying to provide a range
of different flexible options depending
on
you know how people want to manage that
as it relates to
their own life
yeah so the the question on about dark
patterns and and addiction first of all
addiction is um very specific when we
talk about addiction and
and common language we we mean
pathological use and
and loss of control uh so hope
you know uh thank goodness this is
doesn't happen uh that often
um but what we want to care about is as
we
don't um force uh your users or your
players in the case of video games
to stay or to come back or to pay more
so that's uh really the
the difference i i usually i take the uh
the analogy of uh the difference between
a magician
and a pickpocket both of these people
are using um cognitive science and the
the knowledge of
of um our brain limitations um
to do their jobs but the magician does
that with our content
content and it's to entertain us so a
magician
knows very well for example the
limitation of our attention um they use
um a a lot of tricks
to make things appear disappear without
us noticing but we
they do that with our consent and we we
want to be tricked
we want to have you know that that uh uh
that magic feel and it's a win-win
situation you know where we're happy
and the magician did their their job and
they're happy too a pickpocket
is gonna use also the the the knowledge
of the limitation of our attention
to just like steal from us so it's not
with our consent
and and it's uh really exploiting our um
uh limitations to do stuff that is is
not
uh beneficial for us and it's only
beneficial for the pickpocket
so this is the the difference between
the two and when you have a
ux mindset you do the magic you put the
the
the user at the center of what you're
doing and you want a win-win situation
you know the product is working and so
the people are
happy and so your product is going to be
successful because you have that trust
relationship
in games the additional complication
is that people play games to be
entertained and so
we we need to um be you know
to be engaging in in games so that
people can have fun
and the the difference is is when we we
try we try to force people to come back
as at a specific time
otherwise they're going to lose
something that they care about so
it's it's really sometimes really
difficult to navigate these uh gray
areas and this
topic that i really um care about that's
why with a few people we launched
the ethical games initiative to to talk
about all these uh
uh gray areas and where would be the
line
uh when the game is just fun and
engaging and
and when does it start when the the game
is is like tricking people to come back
when they did not really want to that
day so it's a difficult topic
uh it's very nuanced but it's very
important to make that difference
well i personally have never played
fortnite but i keep hearing about how
incredibly engaging it is so i also
appreciate that you and your colleagues
are actively thinking about
the balance and the line between
engaging
and addiction engagement and addiction
so thank you
um celia andrew thank you so much for
joining us today
and sharing your insights and your
experiences with us uh we've learned a
lot about how your respective company
have employed design so thanks so much
yeah thank you thank you
hi everyone thank you so much for
joining us this evening to help kick off
wire25
i'm sonya chopra executive editor of bon
appetit and i'm joined today by
gabriella kamara a chef restaurateur and
cookbook author with decades of
experience
running restaurants in mexico city in
san francisco including the well-loved
contra mar and kala
gabriela has been called one of the most
innovative women in food and drink and
is widely recognized as a leader when it
comes to driving sustainability and
equitable work practices inside the
restaurant industry
with us are john gray pierre serra and
les walker co-founders of ghetto gastro
the bronx-based creative and culinary
collective truly defies boundaries
pushing the limits of what we know as
culinary events to bring people together
and redefine community
the work of both gabriella and ghetto
gastro exists around the intersection of
food art and culture and both place
heavy emphasis on sustainability and
social justice they are pioneers in our
field and have worked hard to push our
industry to be better
please join me in welcoming them today
to get started gabriella i hear you're
going to walk us through making a paloma
yes i chose this drink because i think
it's easy to find ingredients wherever
you are
um it's something that's made usually
or more traditionally with grapefruit
soda so you don't even need the actual
fruit
and i i just thought it was something
really easy everybody
loves it um it's mexican it has tequila
um and it has a little bit of aperol
which
is like my little italian side there so
i'm um i love that drink it's it's
refreshing you can drink it
whenever wherever so are you ready to
give it a shot
yeah i'm ready so i've drank many many
palomas but i've never actually made one
myself so i'm excited about this
you are gonna realize how easy it is
let's see okay you guys i'm so sorry you
can't join in the fun
but you'll learn it it's easy easy easy
do you like tequila or do you prefer
mezcal
in mexico we like people there's a
division between people who only drink
tequila and people who are into
more of the agave i like whichever one
you like
so fine okay this one we're gonna do
with tequila so
do you have your glass okay do you have
a little bit of salt
you need to put a little bit of salt in
a plate so that you can rim the glass
okay so with a lime
do you have a lime around there i have
some
i have some lime juice i was just gonna
dip in yes
perfect that was exactly what i was
gonna ask you to do
perfect so wet the rim
put the salt perfect then
do you have ice cubes around there there
you have ice cubes you don't want it to
be too heavy
you don't want the salt room to be too
heavy and actually some people
like to do just like half of the glass
rim but i think i think that's great
perfect okay because then you're gonna
put the ice cubes in there
okay i have my ice cube in here okay
well maybe this is wrong i was gonna
make it in here and then pour it into
here because i
couldn't get an ice cube to fit into my
mesa jar all right we're doing great
do you have huge ice cubes yeah i have
like big cocktail ice cubes i don't know
okay
fine that's great that's lovely but and
then do you have do you have some
how to do you have a way of shaking it
um i have a
do i need to shake it i was gonna stir
no you don't need to shake it but
it's usually you drink it with the ice
cubes in the drink
i see i see okay fine it's fine okay
let's let's let's
stir and try okay i mean that looks like
good ice so it's not gonna melt that
easily
if you're watching at home please have
smaller ice cubes
yeah that's true just make it there why
not
let's do it it's not very coveted free
to be sharing your drink with anybody so
you just have to finish it
that's true that's true just drink the
whole pitcher okay i'm ready
okay so then you put the ice cubes in
there you
add the tequila which is usually like
one ounce and a half per
per glass okay
i mean this is sort of a light
okay
okay that's half an ounce
perfect that's announced
and then next is the apparel yeah the
apparel and the lime juice exactly
and how much aperol do we want and how
much lime juice you
okay so you want um about an ounce of
lime juice and about uh half an ounce of
april
it's just the aperol is just like to
give it a little bitterness
just a splash or like a full half ounce
or
half an ounce okay
and i'm like i'm worried about spilling
so all my
half ounce pores are a little bit scant
but that's fine i think yeah i just got
my first cooking scale
during the pandemic and so now i feel
like everything i do is so precise and
when i'm not doing something
i'm messing
you're running a bar and wanting to like
take care of costs yes
but if you're doing it at home just make
sure that it's not
either too alcoholic or too sweet all
right i start
doing great you're doing great that's
got some good color there
got the flick of the wrist going the
wrist motion okay so you have
you have the tequila you have the aperol
and you have the lime juice
yep okay and now you just need to be
ready to put the grapefruit soda do you
get a good grapefruit soda
i got what i could find at my bodega so
maybe i won't show you the brand
in case it's the wrong one what's the
right one the hanitos
usually you use like squirt or carritos
yes
usually i mean people but it's also
super i mean it's nicer if you use
grapefruit juice
and a little bit of soda i've been so
sad about the end of tomato season but
you know citrus is coming in strong
so it'll be nice i know it just always
makes up so
like it's so lo it's so happy to have
citrus after using
tomatoes yeah i know okay so top it up
top it up should i should i drink it out
of this or should i pour it into my
mason jar without an ice cube
i really think you should drink from
that okay i'm gonna tell you what you
can do
you can put you can add a little bit of
salt into the glass
since you didn't bring that one because
the salt i mean the salt also makes the
ice
last longer but it's but it's it's
actually really nice to have
a little bit of the salt with the sweet
drink can you confirm what might be
a fake cooking myth to me if you salt if
you heavily salt your water
it takes longer to boil true
i feel like it cooks faster oh it cooks
faster i feel like the water boils
faster when you add salt
yeah i have actually measured it
and it takes exactly the same i don't
know if it's mexico city i don't know
you know with pasta we say you know let
it boil once it's boiling add the salt
it like
goes up again and then and then put the
pasta in
but and i and i've never put the salt
before
the water boils but i actually tried it
once and i measured it with a friend
that was arguing exactly the same thing
and it took like seconds of difference
fascinating cheers cheers did you put a
little bit of salt in there
a little bit of salt and the grapefruit
yeah it's delicious it's balanced
very good so easy can i just say this is
i think it's so appropriate that you're
drinking a paloma sonia because
today we're celebrating mexican
independence day the independence from
spain
over 200 years ago
and many mexicans i hope can be
drinking and celebrating even though
this is a this is a very different
day of independence celebration for the
first time we've had
nobody downtown mexico city and nobody
gathering and nobody
you know everybody's everybody's safe
distancing and socially distancing so
um enjoy your paloma i hope everybody
can make themselves a paloma at least
thank you for walking me through it
thank
happy independence for everybody yes yes
let freedom ring so you mentioned um you
know the difference maybe being in
mexico being here and i was curious you
run restaurants in two countries with
two
totally different sets of policy and two
totally different restaurant rules
and specifically inside of mexico you
work as an advisor to the president of
mexico and
you're on the government's council of
cultural diplomacy so i was just
wondering
how has your work kind of changed and
evolved during this time in the pandemic
can you tell us a little bit about what
it's been like well it i mean it's
absolutely you know it's absolutely
different san francisco
i mean just the difference of climate
you know one city is by the ocean uh sea
level the other one is
high altitude in the mountains um it is
in a plateau and it's super
uh you know mexico city is this like
flat
lovely climate you know it's the the
closeness of the equator makes it really
easy to grow things and we have
an amazing like farmland in mexico city
which is something that many people
don't know about mexico city because
it's so populated
but we actually are able to grow a lot
of our vegetables in mexico city and
then mexico is such a centralized
country that we get
tons of things in the city but anyway
running
restaurants in san francisco and mexico
city yes i could not think of two cities
that are
close-ish like in the big scheme of
the globe uh and so different
san francisco is a very small city 700
000 people living there only um
i don't know i mean there are on the
other hand so many similarities i've
found that san francisco and mexico city
are much more similar than
i expected because i had never lived in
san francisco until 2014 when i went
there
and you know the the abysmal difference
between those who
live well and those who really struggle
in the city
is is a big similarity with mexico city
um
i have seen the growth of homelessness
and
and and you know and drug use in the
street
um people just living in the streets and
people remaining homeless because
it's so difficult to pay a rent in san
francisco so
you know in the bay area in general so
that's been that's been a similarity
like an unfortunate similarity that i
didn't expect that but that we've lived
with on the other hand um you know in
restaurants in restaurants in mexico
city of course
things are more and more uniform and
there are rules that apply to everybody
and there are um there are you know now
with the pandemic we've
learned a lot about how to
keep safe and how to like um
have all these hygiene and
and and labor laws that apply to
absolutely everybody but
in general i find that mexico city is
more about
like knowing where who you need to go
talk to
so that you can get this and this and
this other permit or
having the right uh lawyer to figure out
your
your way through legality and opening a
restaurant in san francisco it's very
difficult to open something
but once it's open then you have it you
know how it is it's sort of very
straightforward mexico city is much more
um much more challenging in
a way but then on the other hand so many
other things are just
easier because things are less
established i find
so i don't know i mean there are so many
differences that one can talk about and
so many similarities
um we could go in terms of ingredients
we can go in terms of
the way people live the way people
eat the way you know people in san
francisco nobody stays
for a long lunch in san francisco in
mexico city everybody who can afford it
just lingers at the table um
people really enjoy each other's company
it's very seldom that one sees one
person eating alone in mexico city in a
restaurant like contrary
in san francisco there are many people
who just come and eat at the bar
um in san francisco everybody finishes
dinner and then they're off
um tacos which is
in the back alley now they're both
closed unfortunately because of the
situation in the city
but um the you know one of the really
interesting things about these two
cities
is like the conventionality of people
around eating for me that's that's the
main difference
i have a question yes plan on going to
oaxaca
maybe for two or three weeks just fall
we got to reconnect and i need you we
gotta reconnect i have so many
suggestions oaxaca is one of the most
fascinating and wonderful places of
mexico
i love it okay so specifically in terms
of dining right now in the pandemic
my understanding is in in mexico city
there's indoor dining in the restaurants
i i live in brooklyn in new york i
haven't been inside a restaurant to eat
in
you know six months probably i'm really
curious to know what that's like and
what it's like as a business owner to to
make that happen
it's so sad the indoor dining is a very
reduced amount of diners in the in the
dining room
is such a such a such a crowded dining
room
and it's really sad to see contra be
so empty because we are you know the
capacity now is
30 percent so and depending on the size
but
you know there's there has to be at
least
a meter and a half um of
of distance between that's like six feet
seven feet
uh between between tables and people at
the restaurant
so so it's really it's it's really
reduced so it's somewhat
sad in a way just in terms of so you've
lost kind of the energy and the vibe of
a space that before was absolutely
predicated on people watching and being
around
absolutely yes absolutely yeah i'm sure
you still have a big target on the menu
though
yes okay okay yes and we have yes
we have we have the food is delicious
but then
a lot of the contaminate experience is
being around
so many people eating and having a great
time
yeah in terms of building a business and
building a team and
kind of fair and equitable practices i'm
curious just in general
is that something that's easier to do in
mexico city or is that something that's
easier to do in san francisco i know
your restaurant in san francisco has a
lot of
policies in place just to make sure that
the workplace is really fair and
inclusive
in mexico it's it's very serious i mean
sort of labor laws are
i think even more so than in the united
states have been more
um preoccupied sort of aware of of
workers needs in general for example
social security is
is an obligation for every employer in
mexico city in mexico in the whole
country
but it's been that way for decades i
mean it's not something new
um in mexico we have we had a revolution
in 1920
and that really changed sort of the
relationship
or at least the constitutional rights of
everybody
um in a way that that was very
you know much more advanced in the
united states for sure and just in terms
of
the government taking care of people
which
which is you know when you have a
corrupt government then
you know the reality ends up being sort
of
not as good as the as as it looks on
paper
but but but that's definitely there's an
awareness that
that we all have sort of lived by in
mexico
yeah i mean i remember at the start of
the pandemic when when it really was on
businesses to decide what to do with
their staff what to do that what feels
fair and it was so difficult for people
to kind of understand and to make those
hard choices with no input from the
government so
you know at a baseline it's nice that
you had that in mexico yes
i also feel that um
yeah in the united states i think i feel
we're still sort of
figuring it all out on our own and it's
also in the united states it's you know
it's a it's a like all the all the
different states have different
regulations so it's it's really very
challenging
i feel that in mexico even though
different states do have
some autonomy it's much more guided by
the like things are much more guided by
the government in a way that
does take it you know that does take
into account
like really essentially workers
compensation and situation
and to the degree that many you know
many business owners are
super frustrated with the government
it's a good segue
um earlier we were talking about the
importance of voting and maybe i'll just
take this
second to say anybody who's listening to
this please vote in november this is
such such an important election here in
the united states and there's so much
that
we can change and that we can do so
please take a second to do everything
you can
it's never enough everybody got it
get those poles put on your gloves get
out there cast those absentee ballots
early don't be afraid
on the voter suppression you know
frighten you
they're doing a lot of work to deter us
from getting out and casting those
ballots so
yeah from new york to new york to
atlanta to louisiana all the way to cali
it's like
every every vote is super important this
year too many people didn't vote
in 2016 and that's how we got in the
place where we are so
thinking that we're rebelling by not
going out and voting you're not going to
get what you want that way we've got to
get out
you got to make change and like that's
the best way for us to change
people in office and the policies
[Music]
make i love it all right so
john pierre how are you i i know you're
going to be cooking for us today but
first i was hoping you could tell me a
little bit about
what exactly you do what exactly is
ghetto gastro
how are you we're here at the location
in the bronx
get on gastro is like we're storytelling
we use
food and experiences around food and
food history to
tell stories about culture life and
vibes really you know activism
art design are all like different
mediums like we like to
employ to spread the message it's
definitely about empowerment
and uh creating creating the
for the next generation of entrepreneurs
creators
outside not only the bronx but for the
world
you know all over new york city to the
world so it's just
us creating catalysts and using our
platform to spread
the knowledge on the food as a weapon
and a weapon of class destruction
educating them to uh take it to the next
level
and degeneration cycles of diseases
food as a weapon is something that you
have talked about a lot and i'm hoping
you can just kind of expand on that
and how kind of food is it used to
oppress certain people and what you're
doing to change that
well i think that i can't remember his
exact name but
he was the secretary of agriculture in
the united states
back um in the 70s and he actually
coined the phrase food as a weapon
and really what what we what we mean by
putin's weapon is
like it's a system that's been designed
in order for
people to be oppressed for people not to
be able to
operate at their optimum self by feeding
them
foods that are full of sugars pesticides
you know processed foods and six of the
ten leading causes
in the united states and amongst
communities of color are
all of the things that we um consume and
put in our bodies
so by us talking about how they use food
as a weapon to oppress we use food as a
weapon to
you know um to arm ourselves to be
ready for everything that that life has
to throw at us so we make sure that
the things that we put in ourselves are
all life you know we we're heavy
plant-based over here
we're not vegans but you know we do have
a diet that predominantly based around
plants
and vegetables and you know just being a
lot more conscious about
the sourcing and the um and about
what we're consuming amongst us
ourselves and our community
and just spreading and spreading that
message because bringing awareness to
the to the situations
a lot of a lot of people haven't
necessarily been
um that focused on things that we put in
our bodies but like
first thing when it comes to health and
like knowledge itself
is everything that you consume the
temple you know you've got to maintain
the temple
and what you put in is what you put out
you know your input
is going to equate to your output so
yeah that's the that's the vibe so tell
us a little bit about what you're making
today
okay so we're gonna switch cameras now
a little studio magic good job y'all see
me and my friends
today i'm making a dish it's a spicy
fruity dish that was
actually the started off as a dish that
i wanted to go get at johnny and venice
um in la i was in la at the time and
evenings were shut down of course due to
covey
and um i really liked the ditch but what
i
what i really wanted to do to the dish
was
um change the narrative on it and make
it a plant-based dish
because i i did not eat dairy at all
so um quarantine gave me the opportunity
to experiment with that and i used
you know plant-based butters plant-based
parmesan cheese
um and i added an addition of my myself
my personal little touch i had some um
quite truffle to it as well so
it became like a white truffle spicy
cassini
um pretty much remix johnny and vinnie's
jump
um and it starts off
by cooking off some
martelli sprucini pasta um this is an
imported facility from from italy
you know we're going to start off as
gabriella said earlier man we're going
to start off by seasoning that
that water from pasta in the meantime
while that pasta
working on our sauce started off with a
little bit of
evil and extra virgin olive oil just to
coat the pan a bit
too crazy some onion
all right let's get that little
translucent in the pan
i was really glad to see that y'all
picked italian food because it segues
kind of nicely into something i wanted
to talk about
which is the i guess you could say like
the dichotomy of
cuisines and the way that people talk
about them here in the u.s
in the last five years i think
especially there's been this kind of
heavy discourse
inside the food world around phrases
like cheap eats right like cheap eats
is indian food it's chinese food it's
mexican food it's soul food these are
foods that people
traditionally don't want to pay extra
money for facility like you said is a
dish that's
pretty easy to make inside a restaurant
you could pay 22 dollars for it but at
home you know it would cost you probably
much less than that
i'm just curious kind of all of your
perspectives on that on this kind of
idea of cheap eats if you think it's
changing i know there's been a lot of
attention drawn to the problems with the
phrase
but do you see in your own experience
somebody who runs mexican restaurants
somebody who's cooking in the bronx you
know an area that a lot of people kind
of
like equivalate with with cheap food are
you are you seeing real chain when it
comes to that phrase and that kind of
idea
well i think i think a big reason why
people look at
food that usually comes from maybe brown
black people
not that i'm not eurocentric it's just
an extension of white supremacy and
how society values peoples and their
creations
so um so hopefully like what we're
trying to do is definitely
disrupt that notion and bring some some
other narratives and i think
like what gabriella is doing um and
with mexican cuisine it's like bringing
it into a context like yo this is a very
technically rich historical
slavers of being layered much like west
african caribbean
and like american cuisines which is when
you think about what american cuisine
really
is is usually rooted in indigenous
and practices that were developed by
enslaved africans
that were being oppressed in the
american south and the north so
yeah what we're doing is with ghetto
gastro is exploring the diaspora
having a lot of different inspirational
influences from our travels abroad
and creating a new language in the space
with those things
and selling it for a lot so they know
that it ain't cheap
and reparations the reparations
i mean that's that's the real issue
right like i mean with mexican food
i can't go on enough you know it's
always been considered in the united
states especially
like cheap food and it has to do with
the population who
consumes it to begin with but i i feel
very proud to have
sort of insisted always to begin with in
my restaurants in mexico
on paying what you need to pay to eat
what you're going to eat
because we as a restaurant industry
we're just subsidizing a lifestyle of
people who
want to you know get the cheapest
version of like a fancy or whatever or
like a sophisticated experience of
or uh you know it takes it takes a lot
as we know like we can't go on enough
about this right
it takes so much to make good food it
takes
like careful learn farming
it takes you know careful learn handling
it takes careful
uh you know careful and good cooking
and good maintenance and good serving
and good everything and why
why is that not gonna be valued in food
like why
are the only important people in the
food chain
consumers final consumers it is so
pathetic
and if we don't get our act together in
that you know in that
in food just in food we have the whole
spectrum
we we really need to get it together and
i think if kova doesn't i mean
before it was challenging but if after
covered we don't do it then then there's
really no
like solving the society in any possible
way
so as diners what can we do support
things that are well done
so you know maybe actually try you know
be conscious of
the need of spending maybe more money on
a dinner than on a t-shirt i mean i
don't know you know it's
there's so many things um but it really
has to do with respect of everybody
who's involved in the process of doing
something or getting something to you
right spend that money like if you're
expecting to have
a world-class taco or any or
whatever the whatever food it may be
cornbread whatever it may be you're
going to expect people to use the best
ingredients
in order for them to get those best the
best ingredients for them to get the
best product
you have to pay and everybody needs to
be compensated all the way down to the
farmers and the people who are laboring
to you know to get that um that final
product to you because not necessarily
it's not just about the final product
and people we tend to be very um
what do you call it selfish when it
comes to eating food like i want this
this is for me but when you remove
yourself and you think about everything
else that's been involved you have a lot
more
appreciation for where it came from
you're not gonna go
you're not gonna go to gabriella's
restaurant and ex uh
you know expect the same thing that
you're gonna get from a taco bell or
anything like that like the levels
and the amount of hands that it touches
and the amount of care that it goes
through
is you know it's night and day so you
pay what you get for like if you want to
go to a world-class restaurant you
should be
ready to you know dig in your pockets a
little bit and especially
but even even when it's not world class
like if it's not like
it's like we have llama radish spot in
the neighborhood and it's like like the
work they're putting into making those
mondays and
it's like real neighbors efforts
ancestral knowledge that
is valuable it's like you can't just put
value on mother sources from escoffier
right you know it is yeah i was gonna
say that you can't i mean
it's not about making making it fancy
and therefore being able to charge
it's about really making it
um responsible throughout the process
like it's about really
it's not really knowing what it takes
and respecting the product
and respecting about and we know that
you know like industrial agriculture
is subsidized and that's why it can be
cheap but it's also it's like it's not
cheap on the long run for so many
reasons it's bad for the environment and
that's expensive
it's bad like there are all these
expenses that aren't taken into account
when we talk about industrialized food
and a society that wants to
have everything there and fast um
i i really i i really take on the slow
food
you know philosophy in terms of that
it's it's not
true that food is cheap good food is not
cheap
nothing that is worth it is cheap like
our our our it's it has to do with our
value system of
what is cheap and what's expensive and
expensive isn't necessarily really
costly expensive is just maybe expensive
because it's
like a merchandising um scheme so i
really i really
feel that we need to re-think about all
the i think we really need to put our
our our attention in the
in the important issues and the
important issues are
the environment the well-being of
everybody the health of everybody
and i i think that this is you know this
is it's the right environment to be
talking about these things
well yeah it's like it's now or never
right you know it's like
are you kidding if it's not now why
didn't seriously that would really do
forever
yeah and if anybody doesn't know like
really the sort of effort that it takes
it's like just try to grow some tomatoes
and see and just try to grow like one
tomato plant see how much effort and
time
it takes you to get your tomato plant
from seed
to to actual product and then turning
that into something and like imagine
that for every
ingredient that has to go into your dish
it's like it takes
it takes time and care and like that's
also what you spend the money on is the
time
it's like you have to pay people then
when you do take care of a tomato plant
and you realize how many tomatoes you
actually can get from a tomato plant
then you get into the whole other thing
of oh my goodness and what do you do
to conserve them and how do you keep
them and how do you actually manage to
use up all the tomatoes that you have
in one like two weeks of the year right
so that i really feel that in terms
you know just for all of us to really
appreciate food
i do believe that gardening is an
important part of it just
like to get that experience to know what
it's like
or yeah well i feel like people don't
use their time
i feel like people choose to use their
time differently right like
you could the same amount of time that
like when you come home from work that
you spend time like watching tv
or doing something else you could
actually take that sort of time and
dedicate it to
focusing on your garden and if you you
know if you have the space but focusing
on things that
will help bring you know more make a
more sustainable lifestyle really
yeah well i mean i think that's one of
the issues in the us is that we've we've
started to treat food as a convenience
thing or a luxury thing right and
you've kind of lost that whole spectrum
in between but i want to go back
you mentioned tomatoes and we have
somebody cooking a pasta sauce for us
and i think we should
do this so we back now
um so the sauce was cooked down and i'll
do it in a blender
this is um okay this is canned tomate
this is canned on tomato
imported from italy caramelized onion
garlic red chili flake
maldon salt we're going to blend this
while he's blending i'm going to ask you
a question when you caramelize onions
how long does it take you
so i just caramelized it until it has a
slight amber color to it
so with that is bringing another level
to the
flavor composition of it because the
sugar is naturally coming out of the
onion
as opposed to a raw onion where you're
going to get a very
acidic flavor when you caramelize it you
get more of
a more subtle sweet caramelized flavor
and you add the garlic and cook that
garlic out then we add the tomato
the tomato paste and then we pause it
for a second
so this is the uh myocos plant-based
butter
this is 100 dairy free guilt-free
you can enjoy it and not feel
bad you didn't hurt any animals
all right you got some
some plant-based parmesan as well
is that made from almonds the
plant-based parmesan is actually made
from
cashews okay cashews cultures
um nutritional yeast i feel like
nutritional yeast has really had a
moment during the pandemic too here in
the u.s
so the pasta is already done we got the
sauce done already
so now we're going to go into the pan
cook pasta
this is the sauce after it's blended you
got a nice color to it
i love it this is a super simple dish
too like it's good to do with your kids
at home good they include family members
and uh it's really tasty as well
gabriella how do you feel about cashew
based parmesan cheese
i feel that if it's good it's great
so me personally i'm into spice i don't
know if you guys are
but i'm into spice so i added a touch a
bit more
contouring to my touch of chili oil
and uh some white truffle oil
make it pop with those truffles man
and there you have it a little margaret
salt
i'm gonna plate this and will you tell
us a little bit about john and vinnie's
while you're plating that giant vinnies
is an italian spot in l.a
really really known for their authentic
postures
really known for their authentic italian
cuisine
and they're the homies man we met him in
um in copenhagen
in 2015 and ever since then you know we
just been we've just been shooting
nick kicking it with those guys and when
i'm in la i run down on them and i go
get the uh
you know i get the chicken parmesan i
get the mushrooms i get pizzas they're
really well known for their
brick oven pizzas their fire
is it true that y'all also met gabriela
in copenhagen
yeah that's true as soon as this offers
some garlic chips
just for some texture that's fried
garlic
yes this is these are garlic chips that
i've blanched twice
i blanched them twice and then i and
then i slow fry them
and that's that beautiful
mmm
do the garlic chips last forever you can
actually keep these garlic chips
in your pantry for up to up to a few
months at a time
i don't think they'll last a few months
because
and i like to put them on any everything
i even crush them up and i
mix them up with my panko crumbs when i
when i finish like a
mac and steez with some good old or some
good um
panko crust i crush up some garlic chips
and uh
finished uh finished a lot of dishes off
with that as well so
it lasts a while because of the route
because they're blanched twice
and they're slowly fried so it's you
know we take all of that moisture out of
them and they last a pretty long time
that's great okay so we've talked about
sustainability
quite a bit and i i just wanted to kind
of hear from you all
what's your advice for people who want
to do more when it comes to
sustainability
but they're not quite sure where to
start well before we get into i just
want to say that
one of the things that's super um i
guess ironic about the bronx it's the
home to the largest food distribution
center of its kind in the world i mean
it's a really big fish market only
second inside tuskegee in tokyo
the meat market and the produce market
yet our community is one of the most
insecure food insecure
in the city and then we also have the
poorest congressional district
in the country and a lot of the truck
traffic that
um we deal with the fossil fuel
emissions that we do
from the trucks that deliver the food
from the distribution center
elsewhere around the city and around the
northeast
result in high asthma rates high
hypertension
and then we don't have the nutritious
food stuffs
in the community but i'll let peon let's
get into
how a home cook at home could work on
being more
sustainable and less wasteful yeah i
think um in terms of
being more sustainable as home cooks
just be more realistic with
your schedule and know you know what you
have lying ahead
if you have a busy week ahead of you
that you have planned out maybe you
don't
do as big of a grocery shop if you're
not going to be at home if you're not
going to be at home as much
what i like to do is like if i know i'm
going to be busy i like to prep meals
ahead of time
so if i have like a big pot of soup or
any anything large like a lasagna or
anything like that i'll make
i'll make a big batch and keep some in
the freezer or just put more in the
fridge and then if you
tend to like over shop and you have
extra onions garlic tomatoes any extra
herbs
um peppers etc etc you can even make
practice making stocks practice
preserving things um preservation
methods it sounds like it's a lot but
it's really not
it's like having a mason jar with the
lid and putting it putting some tomatoes
and uh
you know putting a mason jar in a pot
and a pot of water
so that it's barely covered and you can
you know you can preserve your tomatoes
your peaches
you can make jams and stuff just get a
little more creative make a sofrito make
a big
batch of sofrito freeze it inside of ice
ice cube trays so that you can have easy
access
fat to fast cooking and tasty cooking um
as well so
just exploring different things not
trying not to throw stuff
out really um i think that's one major
way maybe getting a good water
filtration system in your home so you
don't have to
so you can steer yourself away from
using single-use plastic
well pete touched on a lot of really
good points but
um and as well i like to practice
compost
i like to practice compost i'm really
into juicing so
a lot of products that where i might
have the root left over
or i might have extra leaves left over
things of that nature i juice those and
we work with lava rider in their garden
and
you know we help them out by providing
them with the compost that we have
in our homes in the compost in the bronx
community
so there's a lot of things that you can
do to pro
to um add to the equity of your
community by composting
i could not agree more these small
things can actually make a huge
difference in your food waste and you're
just taking advantage of everything that
you have if you go to the market then
you need to
learn how to actually use up everything
because
the worst thing is to go to the farmers
market get amazing produce and then not
use it
which i think happens for a lot of
people so that's why you need to be
really careful with what you
buy and how you you just to think of
what you're going to do with everything
that you have
exactly and pay attention to what ghetto
gastro is doing and what gabriella is
doing man so you get these tips
and you get these isms and this
absolutely
so as we're wrapping up one last
question how can we support you
well we have um we just released a
waffle maker and then we have a whole
appliance line coming out
called crux gg available exclusively at
williams sonoma
you know so so that kind of percentage
of the proceeds go to support
organizations like
we think who we've been working with la
mirada feeding people
um as our kovit response but also the
know your rights campaign
because as we know it's two pandemics
you know you have closing
also in the murdering of black people
in the united states so we're fighting
both of those closes and you know
it's the black power kitchen so just
tune in tell a friend to tell a friend
watch the content on instagram and check
in we've also got some food products
dropping
towards the holidays so just just just
you know
keep the cycle going recycling your
black and brown dollars you know
taboo i love it gabriella what about you
how can we support you uh i guess by
just
keeping on you know coming to the
restaurants
um i think you know you can support by
again being conscious being aware of all
the perma
you know pertinent issues um voting as
we said
you know i think it's a time to really
hold on to each other and
to the causes that we believe in in
every
in every way in every aspect of our
lives thank you you know what's so crazy
i just i just saw mexico sent
firefighters to america
yeah to help with the fires and nothing
in the northwest so i'm like
let's just think that's let that center
when the current administration in the
united states has
a lot of negative things to say about
mexico but mexico is sending us
help when we need it you know so i just
want everybody to let that's thinking
as they go to register hit those polls
and all of these things and the mexicans
are native to
to america before everybody else so
let's also know that as well so
california was mexico it is mexico
indigenous there are so many mexicans
legally and illegally in the united
states
and you know that was i don't know if
you all heard the
uh speech of the mexican president when
he finally went to see trump which was
like a huge historic thing
because they do not agree i think um i
don't think they agree on many things
but uh the on many important things but
one of the things the president said is
you know
just let's all be aware of how
intertwined these two countries are
so yes let's be let's let's you know
let's
let's be as good neighbors as we can and
not only good neighbors but just like
you know good humans to whomever needs
it around us
absolutely spread love spreading love
um i just want to say thank you so much
thank you gabriella thank you ghetto
gastro for
taking the time to walk us through your
recipes for talking about these
important issues thank you wired25
for giving us the space to talk about
these things and um everybody have a
great night
thank you sonia gabriella if you if you
still got my number send me a text
i'll definitely i'll definitely want to
talk about that oaxaca
and it's so good to see let's let's see
guys it's so nice to see you three
so nice keep up the good work i love it
i love you
love you too love you too bye
candy man the urban legend is if you say
his name five times while looking in the
mirror
he appears in the reflection and kills
you i would do that
[Music]
candy man candy man
candy man
well we're still alive
let's go
trina you broke the door
[Music]
i feel really connected to this
neighborhood
cabrini green it was the projects
i just moved in around the corner the
old candy factory i'm an artist
you're looking for candy man
he's the monster that's part of this
neighborhood
why are you drawn to this i'm hoping to
spread the story all about candyman
the mirror invites you to summon him
you should say his name i dare you
candyman
candyman candyman candyman
no don't say that
hi everybody i'm jason parham i'm a
senior writer at wired where i cover pop
culture
i could not be more thrilled today i'm
joined by nia de costa
she's a director screenwriter she's
behind me hugely hugely hot
anticipated horror project candyman
which drops next year
nia thank you so much for being with us
today hi
thank you so much for having me i'm
really excited to be here to give the
audience a little bit of context
nia's first project from 2019 little
woods would start tessa thompson and
lily james
centered on two sisters in a north
dakota oil boom town
it unpacked a lot of important issues
around gender around housing around
health care
around drug addiction so we're
definitely going to dig into that a bit
as well
it's also reported that nia landed one
of the most coveted gigs in hollywood
she'll be directing captain marvel 2.
so nia thank you so much for being with
us today so we just saw the trailer for
candy man not dying snow were you a fan
of horror films growing up
i was a huge fan of horror films growing
up um i would
like i would go to my grandma's house
after school and i would turn off all
the lights before she got back from work
and
watch like tales from the crypt and like
any horror movies i can get my hand on
um and yeah i was super super into them
and
candy man was one of the big ones that
was very
very large in my childhood um but before
i even saw it i was being dared to say
it
um in the mirror his name five times in
the bathroom at school which i refused
to do of course
um but yeah i love horror films was
there anything about the original that's
you know that stood out in your mind as
a child growing up that you took into
the film when you were making the film
oh man yeah i think the first one was so
unique
and it's this style is really specific
and
and different and it really feels like a
bit of a fewer dream you know uh
watching this woman's descent and and
candyman of course
tony todd as candy man is so iconic and
so
such an impressive new kind of uh
villain
um at least in the context of the 1992
film and so yeah this really
thinking about him as this iconic
character and wanting to pull back the
layers and expand more on on what that
actually means and who candy man is what
candyman is
um was was what i wanted to bring into
the you know this version
so your version does so much visually
structurally i got to see a preview of
it it's amazing
talk to me a little bit about your
choices um how did you go about making
this version your own
right yeah um yes yeah it's like a
million little decisions you know every
day but for me
what i love so much about the original
is how unique it is is how specific it
is it is a filmmaker's vision
and so insofar as i was able to i really
wanted to
make this feel like you know a very
specific unique
visual um visually interesting film
and not just like a horror with some
people dying and who cares
um and the other thing other thing is
you know we really wanted to
expand on the mythology so from you know
the very first draft of the script that
i read before i officially was on the
film
um there was this criminal there of like
okay there's more to candy man than just
this guy named daniel robitaille there's
um there's more to the idea of candyman
um and so that too i think was and
thinking about the first one what i
wanted to bring to this one just like
more so now you collaborated with jordan
pill on the script
who many consider the hitchcock air
parent what was it like working with him
on this project
um it was cool uh i think my favorite
part of the process with jordan was
just sitting in a room together and like
shooting ideas back and forth and seeing
how his mind works and
um and just like watching him work and
and just being able to create something
that's always my favorite part of the
process when i'm collaborating
especially on
at the writing stage um so yeah it was
really cool like i'm a huge fan of
get out and and i love key and peel so
um
um sometimes i'd like reference a skit
and he'd be like that's a real deep cut
i'm like i've watched it so many times
but yeah it's really fun it was great
so the movie which i love it's sort of
it
it merges the past and the present and
thread so many themes together
police brutality a history of lynching
gentrification
sort of white depth of black capital um
what i like to call sort of everyday
horrors or social horrors
um so why do you think or why would you
say the horror genre which are working
as such a right vehicle to bring
attention to these injustices i think
what's great about horror is that you
can um you can layer like the horror the
physical of like
being in a space and being worried about
someone about to get you know killed by
a killer or or haunted you know in a
haunted house or
or any of those things and you can just
easily lay on the whole like personal
horrors real life force onto these
these um these tropes as like metaphor
and
what's what's great about horror is a
horse stays with you after you live in
the theater
um i mean you can say every great film
stays with you but horror really like
it's in your psyche it like gets deeper
into
into your brain i think understanding
how
a horrible ghost or a serial killer or
whatever can be as um
tangible for people who don't understand
like black trauma and black war or black
pain
um it could be as tangible for them in
the moment they're watching the film and
hopefully when they leave the theater
it's
it's it's sitting with that um not just
like the oh like a
ghost but also with oh like real pain of
people that
are part of my community so that's what
i think is useful about horror
um in that context but there are so many
of course ways to tell
the stories that we're telling right so
speaking of the so many ways to tell
those stories i'm curious in what ways
do you see candyman being a bridge
between sort of
the original slasher trilogy horror
classics like nightmare on elm street
and the future of the genre with stuff
like a lot of craft country on hbo
yeah so i guess i'll address like the
freddy krueger
you know of it um candy man himself is
an iconic
uh villain and so i think what
we're able to do in this film is like
pull back the the curtain on like what
makes a villain
who who calls a monster a monster who
decides that
um that's a lot of what our story is
about um and how we how we tell
stories to scare each other protect each
other um
uplift each other and they could kind of
all be the same story um
the future of the genre i think it's
great that there are more black voices
in the genre
um i like that it's more um
feels more potent you know talking about
real life
horrors um and and um
disseminating that you know further into
the culture
um and so i'm just excited in particular
in horror just to see more
more of that but also more different
kinds of stories you know i'd love to
see black people
in in horror films and in horror in the
horror space that's not just about
this kind of trauma and pain but can
also be you know about about
other aspects of our existence um and
there's so much space for that um in
film in general but especially in horror
i think you said it right too it's like
what who is the monster exactly in the
sort of candyman your film is sort of
almost doing that too it's like
who was turning it's sort of the
original question on its head so
yeah definitely so there's a line in the
film that really grabbed me um that
really kind of speaks to our present
moment
um and without giving away too much i
want to engage a little bit um the line
goes
they love what we make and not us and so
i'm
curious as a creative do you see that
and say
how can i reorient that kind of thinking
with my work
or is your job as an artist not to find
value in those systems of thinking
i guess maybe a more clear line of
questioning is do you take on that
burden of making the larger
world love and see our beauty in
whatever way you can or is the work for
you about something else entirely
um i think it's all those things and and
more you know it's it's
at once sort of you know just having
that line in there because a lot of
people have mentioned it which i'm
really happy about just having a light
in there is just like
i think a lot of black creatives and and
you know creators of color
think about all the time it's like i
think in particular for black creatives
like especially if you're like
a musician and you do hip hop or rap you
know like hip hop's the most popular
genre of music now um and yet you know
i'll go to like a kendrick lamar concert
and hear
like the white teens in the front row
saying the n word like you know rapping
along
and so it's like okay you love this
music you love him but you don't
understand what he's saying because if
you understood it you wouldn't be out
here yelling
downward um and making like finger guns
and being ridiculous you know what i
mean
and so that's what i mean it's like you
you love this culture you love how it
makes you feel you love you know the
look of it you love how makes you feel
cool you love
sneakers whatever but you don't
understand the people you don't see the
people as people
um they're just like there to entertain
you and so
um so that's sort of what that means i
think in particular for an artist like
anthony
um whose work is so personal it's like
direct from him to the canvas
to the audience um he he kind of you
leave the building as an artist once
your heart's out there
and um and so for me i i hope that i can
i can create full characters
full humans that the audience can
empathize with
um so that you know one day it's not
like oh they love what we make but not
us it's like oh they love what we make
and they understand us
um but i also some i you know i also
feel like the burden of like trying to
explain to white people
is is so inside of so many black films
and i'd love to eliminate that as soon
as possible um i think so for me i kind
of i try to come
at it from the point of view of i'm
giving you full fully fledged characters
full human beings uh like i hope you
empathize with them i hope you
understand them but i i can't teach you
how to do it
you know so one of my favorite things
that candyman does
um it's such a film about place and
setting
it takes place in chicago and the
cabrini green projects
um your debut feature from last year
little woods was set in this
sort of small rural north dakota town um
both films have such a strong sense of
place
um almost as if these these cities are
characters themselves
um why is that important to your
filmmaking and how does like
change that heighten the film exactly
yeah i think place is super important
because
your environment still influences um how
you feel about yourself how you interact
with your world
i mean i think we're all we're all at
home right now we really are
understanding how much like
our our homes are important to our sense
of self our sense of well-being
our our neighborhoods um and and so
it just has to be a part of the
character uh journey the characters
study that that i present in the films
that i make
um and then with candyman you know it
was so important to go back to cabrini
green
um and the fact that cabrini green
doesn't really exist
in the way that it did in the 1972 film
is why the film
you know even deals with gentrification
um
and tries to look at the many different
ways that racial violence can exist and
manifest in the world
um so yeah this environment's super
important it's it's
man especially in a country like ours
where you know like we're dealing with
like redlining housing segregation
gerrymandering it's like so important
and you know so you um so i'm going to
dial it back just a little bit and go
back to your first film
um little woods was your breakout hit
from last year
it was about two strange sisters in
north dakota who were sort of
doing what they needed to get by to
survive um how did this story come to
you and
and why was it important to tell yeah so
that one
started from me wanting to tell a story
about two women living in a rural part
of america
and dealing with poverty and i knew that
i wanted it to
to focus on health care and how hard
that access is
um and because women dealing with
healthcare i knew abortion and
you know reproductive health is gonna be
a really important part of it and so
i wanted to find the place in america
that would be the most difficult for a
character to
to obtain an abortion and it happened to
be at the time this part of northwest
north dakota
and once i said it there it's like okay
there's the oil booms happening there's
an opiate crisis happening there
um like the ratio of men to women is
like 4-1 you know it's really a specific
sort of wild west sort of place and so
that informed so much
of the film you know the genre the the
characters that we meet how
the sisters interact with each other and
engage with each other um the fact that
it was you know a black main character
in a majority white
place um that was all informed by the
place actually so
um that's how it all kind of came
together just having this one kernel of
an idea two women poor rural america
and then it went from there and what was
it like tesla
has such an amazing performance and what
was it like working with tessa
oh it's amazing it was so great i mean i
got a
little preview because we worked
together at the sundance director's lab
where i workshopped a couple of scenes
from the from the script and
and like you're not really like supposed
to do that thinking you're gonna cast
whatever actors come out to like
workshop with you but
um she was just she just became
uh the character you know and i was like
oh it has to be her
um she's great i love her silver dearly
um
excellent actress obviously but also an
amazing collaborator
incredibly intelligent incredibly
creative um and she really gives a
i mean you can tell from everything that
she's been doing like she really gives a
so it was wonderful so what's really
fascinating to me about little woods is
it moves almost like it's a it's a
thriller but it moves like a western a
little bit
candy man is also sort of like decidedly
a horror film and like social commentary
a bit
um it's also rumored that you're working
on a big superhero marvel film
um do you see genre work as a challenge
or an opportunity
and also um yeah i think genre work is
challenging
in that it's not just about the truth um
with genre
it also just has to be like effective
you have to kind of manipulate it it's
really psychological you have to figure
out like
you know the buttons and like figure out
how to push buttons in the audience and
whatnot
um if it's a drama like a straight drama
i kind of find straight drama
it's not easy but like the easiest
because it's really just like
okay who are my characters what are the
stakes like let's be honest let's tell
the truth you know
um but genre is great because one people
watch it so it's usually
um you know it's great just to have
people watching your stuff um because
then the message or if there is a
message even um and whatever you're
trying to say or
you know proliferates more which is
exciting um and it's an opportunity
because
because more people see it but also
because i think
people know what to expect when they go
into a comedy or horror film or thriller
and so you can do two things one you can
lull them into a sense of security while
you
you know do your work you know inside of
inside of the genre trappings
and then you can also surprise them um
in ways that are exciting and thrilling
for them
um so there's a lot of opportunity there
and i think that's why it's so
exciting do you see yourself drawn to
any particular genre
as an artist or as a director as a
creator like there's one speaking more
than the other
not as a whole but i i do know like no
matter what i do i tend to want to have
like a lot of tension and like
frillerish sort of elements to it
um not in everything that i've done but
um
for the most part like even if i'm doing
like
um yeah like you know
little woods is a western this is a
horror film um you know i wrote like an
adaptation of the nimson play like i was
just like more thriller elements you
know
more like tension and that's really
something i really like doing
so nia before we wrap up i want to bring
us back to the present moment for a
second um
you also have to have a huge summer
release and now kenny man is dropping
that cheer
many people are still kind of scared of
going to the theater getting sick in a
crowded theater
i'm curious for you how do you feel
about releasing a movie during the
pandemic
yeah i mean it's so my
my ideal for the film is to come out in
theaters when it
when it's safe and so
you know we'll see when that is um
but that's really what i want i want
people to be able to
to enjoy the film on the big screen but
when it's safe and when
um you know it makes sense
so what lasting effect do you think the
pandemic will have on the moving
industry
are you helpful oh wow um you know
people are so fatalistic about like
theatrical uh distribution the words
like theaters are dying you know
etcetera etcetera
um but i really think two things happen
one we realize things that we don't have
to do together you know which is useful
for workflow and that kind of thing and
um i think also opens up to more people
getting more opportunities
um and then as when it comes to like
theatrical i think
what a lot of what we learned during the
pandemic is not just what we can do um
without having to be there but also what
we really would love to do
together and i think going to a theater
is one of those things so i think like
people are going to always go see see
movies in theaters and i think this is a
moment where it's like oh yeah like
i would love to have the opportunity to
do that again so um
what we're gonna see in the immediate i
feel like is a lot of things where it's
like
oh it's two characters in a house and
they don't really have to be near each
other so that's the movie
um a lot more tv a lot more animated um
a lot more animation um a lot more
podcasts you know like i think it's
gonna be things that people can do
separately
um but at the same time like you know
movies can't exist in this that one
space so
um when when it's time and when things
are right i think things will
bounce back but i think we'll probably
be safer and more efficient
if i'm being honest and then lastly what
impact do you want to have on society
through your work and your art
oh man um i mean i said this from
from like little woods times um really
just want to spread empathy
and to present really full characters
and people
um to the audiences who come to see my
films
um empathy i think is so important and
it's it's
it's sort of like the secret backbone of
society it's not just like oh if you do
something bad you're gonna end up in
jail or whatever it's also like oh i
care about
people i don't know anything about
because we're both here we're both alive
you know we're both humans in this
community together so empathy is a big
is a big thing for me
i couldn't think of a better thing to
end on thank you again so much nia for
speaking with me today
thank you for having me coming up to
wire25 um and goodbye
[Music]
this is dan jones i'm a television host
i'm also an activist and a dad
and i'm very concerned about the country
we are at a turning point
we're either going to turn to each other
or on each other
follow your dreams we need to
acknowledge what we're trying to do here
in the united states of america is very
very tough
it's hard you got every kind of human
being
ever born in one country as with all
hard things
there comes a time when you gotta
redouble your efforts to listen to each
other
and make any kind of progress rehearsing
sound everybody quiet on the set
that's when i decided to begin working
with elijah allen blitz
on a series of virtual reality
experiences designed to create
true empathy by putting the viewer in
somebody else's shoes
i've always been a fan of marvel comics
and i felt like it was important to find
superheroes who want to do good
in real life for our first episode we
partnered with winston duke
from the film black panther the episode
puts you in the shoes of a 12 year old
african-american boy
in the car with your dad pulled over and
harassed by the police
i'm more interested in white america
seeing it
we wanted to make this available to as
many people as possible
i was a beach cop down in delaware uh so
i got the police officer's perspective
whenever
we hear a story like this happens in the
news it's easy to say
you know at least from my perspective
safety first really gives you
a really new perspective of sitting that
seat as a kid watching dad
get pulled out and you don't know what's
gonna happen next
we used first ever hand tracking
technology that puts the viewer in the
body of the person
they might initially felt like they got
nothing in common with
what these people were experiencing in
three and a half minutes you could argue
about for three and a half
days it's kind of shocking to see with
your own eyes
and to feel yes exactly
for the second episode we decided to
focus on sexual harassment
and to do that we partnered with captain
marvel herself brie larson
i wanted to focus specifically on the
restaurant industry
as a way of insight into a larger
systemic issue
of power imbalances being able to
participate in putting someone in that
experience of seeing how
even microaggressions can be really
impactful
hurtful and traumatizing to others i
think will
help us to create safer fair work
environments for everyone
we do have other episodes with other
marvel superheroes
already lined up just a few decades ago
what we do every single day was
considered impossible
but here we are a miracle in human
history
and we need tools to help us come
together
we're always told like live in someone
else's shoes
there's a difference between living in
someone else's shoes and seeing through
someone else's eyes
hello everybody i'm angela waterketter
senior editor
and for culture here at wired thank you
so much for joining us for wired25 uh
today i'm pleased to be joined by
uh van jones the founder president of
magic labs the ceo for form alliance
and cnn host and contributor elijah
allen blitz virtual reality director and
of course
actress filmmaker producer and captain
marvel herself brie larson
thank you guys so much for joining us uh
it's really great to have you
good to be here thank you for having us
great great
um so obviously we're talking about uh
the messy truth
the vr experience which actually was
also nominated for an emmy i want to say
congratulations to you guys for that
um but first you know um van why don't
you
take us back a little bit um you know we
got a little bit of a glimpse in the the
video we just saw
of what the messy truth is but you know
tell us a little bit about the history
of it you know kind of where
this project came from and why you
wanted why you want to work on something
like this
well uh first of all it's just a big
honor to be here uh
i'm a wired fanatic so it's just good to
be in this conversation and
you know i am a part of an industry that
some people say is tearing the country
apart
uh you know mainstream media uh
so-called corporate media some people
say that the business model
is making it more profitable to divide
people and to bring people together
and uh i don't want to believe that's
true but i want to make sure i'm doing
everything i can
to use technology for good uh is there a
way
for us to use uh uh virtual reality and
anything else
to get people together we just heard
that incredible filmmaker
i was talking about empathy and she
talked about how empathy
is sort of you know the backbone for
human civilization and i think that
she's right
and you know i was so sad about you know
after
the trump victory and all of just the
the
the the pain and suffering and division
and misunderstanding going on across the
country and somebody who grew up in red
state america got a lot of love for red
state america
raised my family on blue coast i just
wanted is it
jesus anyway we could get people
together and then i got a chance to
spend some time with elijah
and elijah is just a genius for
uh of bringing people together finding
solutions
using technology and innovative ways and
he said there's something called an
empathy machine
virtual reality it's just never been
used
uh you know to really solve a social
problem before
and i said well can we try and he said
let's do it and here we are with an emmy
nomination and
and mega stars like brie larson involved
and it's just an amazing
experience uh yeah well that teased up
perfectly elijah tell me a little bit
about you know how you got involved in
this
and sort of what you wanted to do when
you know once you started working with
van on this project
oh yeah i mean from the beginning we
van and i were actually working on
something separate but it when once
trump got elected it was
less than a week after the election we
got on the phone and just both agreed
we need to do something and we need to
see if we can use the power of this
technology
to actually instead of dividing us like
all the stuff that we've seen happening
over the last four years to see if we
can actually bring us together
so this has been beyond a labor of love
this is
an actually it's in a real way it's a
social experiment and we're trying to
see that if we can use this
new medium in vr to actually you know
put you in the shoes of someone else
where you look down
and you're fully embodied for these
experiences in in the you know
shoes of a different race or someone
from a different gender and to really
see like van saying if this can be the
ultimate empathy machine
yeah and bri talk about your involvement
how did you come on board and what
really made you want to work on
something like this
elijah and i had a conversation about it
it was like the first conversation we
ever had was about empathy
and when he was talking about this
project i was
in the midst of working in times up and
i was like oh
we need to talk about tipped workers
it's
a lot of what we're talking about with
trying to put someone in someone else's
shoes i think one place that this really
excels is dealing with power imbalance
because it's an experience that
you have to it's very hard to have if
your body limits you and you've never
been in that experience before
this gives you a never before experience
so we started talking with um roc
and many women in the restaurant
industry and collected a bunch of
stories
um it's important i think to say that
this project is
they're true stories so when you're
going inside somebody else's experience
we're not fictionalizing this we're just
telling the truth and allowing you to
sit in it and feel it for yourself
yeah well you know and for all three of
you you know talk a little bit about
that because i think one of the great
things about vr
is that you can have an experience a
sort of first person perspective
experience on something that you maybe
haven't
been through you know in your own life
but at the same time it's so
intimate to the point where it can be
almost overwhelming
um and so you know how do you find that
balance and you know
how are you trying to reach that balance
between creating empathy but without
sort of
almost having a kind of traumatic
experience or a kind of like i said
overwhelming experience
um for viewers who were kind of doing
some of these things for the first time
you know we actually
oh i was just going to say that you know
that was something we had to work really
hard on
was i when i ate like bree was saying
identifying these stories and
making sure everything's true but then
also b making sure that it wasn't
something
that could potentially traumatize the
viewer so if it was the right mix
finding the right mix of you know both
of these different episodes that we've
created so far
have to give you an emotional connection
where something happens that draws you
in and connects you to the
what you're witnessing but then also at
the same time acknowledging the power of
this medium
where we're not going to give you an
experience that could potentially
traumatize you
yeah yeah just just saying you know
you know the ethics you know that elijah
brought to this i think is really really
extraordinary i mean
be very easy uh to find a story that
would be so
shocking and you know people would jump
out there so you can go home and cry or
whatever but
that's not the point you know what we're
trying to do is find true stories
you know if you you take a story like
being a kid in a car
with your parents everybody's been there
before but when the lights start
flashing behind you and you get pulled
over and you're a black kid
you never forget that well i walk around
with that every black person walks
around with that
if you're a white person you've probably
never had that experience or if you did
it worked out fine it was officer
friendly
you know maybe she's giving you
directions or something um
or just giving you a warning let me go
home so we had to find an experience
that would put you in that tension put
you in that
that that that moment of holy crap like
this is really going badly
but then not have it so bad that you're
just you're traumatized and so
uh it's people say well how can you find
these stories listen the stories are
ubiquitous there's so many stories of
gender discrimination sexual harassment
racial harassment
but how do you find one that's touching
that's moving that doesn't traumatize
people that had to do with the
ethics of the director which is elijah
we actually had a uh a viewer question
uh thanks andrea uh wanted to know
i think from brie specifically you know
how is it different
working in vr versus working you know in
traditional film you know what were the
things that you kind of had to
learn on the fly or learn on the spot
and you know how did you kind of
incorporate that into
into what you do sure so
the thing with this particular piece is
that it's
one continuous scene uh about three
minutes long
right each one's about three minutes
long so it's like a play there's no
coverage so if i mess up a line you
start from the beginning
if you want to try something in a
different direction it's a whole new
take and so
the day is just the beauty of it is you
just need one
take um and the other side of it is that
it's just you gotta encapsulate it all
in one one go through so it's more like
for this particular one it's more like a
play or doing a very short play than it
is
a traditional filming day and the other
piece is as a producer on this is you're
thinking about the space and i learned a
lot from elijah about that
about you know where the camera's placed
where it is in a corner for example so
that because you initially you want to
look around and see but then having a
general focal point
so we work together um from both of our
backgrounds and in order to kind of
streamline this
so that you're getting or maximizing the
impact within the experience
yeah um i think uh van and maybe elijah
as well we saw in the video that you it
looks like you took the
you took this to cpac and actually you
know
gave gave it to some people to try out
talk a little bit about about that
experience you know why you want to do
it and also you know kind of what
you walked away from that experience
with
well look i this is a part of my life um
i
am you know strong democrat work for
president obama
um i'm uh you know i'm at cnn i'm not at
fox
uh and yet i have found that when you
really care about the people who are at
the bottom
uh people who are desperately poor or
who are
addicted or who are in prison or who
have mental health issues
those folks whether you're talking about
appalachia the hood
the native american reservation uh the
border
they tend to have the same basic
problems about 80 percent overlap might
have a little bit more racism here
a little bit more classism over there
but you've got the same basic
problems and neither political party
from my point of view does enough
to help the addicted be afflicted and
the convicted
and so i've never been able to get a
bill passed or get something done to
help anybody where i didn't wind up
working with republicans and democrats
so i'm bipartisan
because i'm so passionate about my
progressive values and what we want to
do is to take this experience to cpac
take it to the biggest gathering of
conservatives
uh uh you know in this hemisphere and
just
open our hearts up and say here's what
here's what uh you know we've got to to
share with you
and we saw people taking off their maga
hats taking out their make america great
hats taking off their
nra hats and putting on those visors and
as you saw in that video
three and a half minutes later saying i
didn't
understand before i didn't understand
what it meant to be an african-american
kid
in a car getting pulled over by police
officers with police dogs etc
i just had never thought about it and
all we want is more understanding
we didn't go there to get them to change
who they're going to vote for i mean
democracy can vote for you that's the
whole point dictatorship
you can only vote for one person
democracy you vote for who you want to
but we want people to vote with more
understanding
and after the election to be able to
have more understanding and that's what
we i think we
achieved a little bit of cpac yeah yeah
you know there was what we were going to
say
oh no just to answer the the yeah just
to elaborate on
daniel van's point about cpac one of the
guiding principles from the beginning of
this project is something van always
says that there's no throwaway people
and that goes across the entire board
and so when you know showing up there
for me that was
my first time at cpac for sure and i
definitely did not know what to expect
but what i was immediately hit by is
that we
all have so much more in common than not
and there i mean there was like van
saying there was you know police
officers that came and watched this
experience
and they were just coming out be like i
have a whole new perspective and
to be able to do that to me that's the
goal of this project
it's not just to show people you know
that agree with our perspective already
it's not to preach to the choir
it's to go out there and try and connect
with people and you know with brie's
episode
we plan to take that out but as soon as
we can obviously not
this is not the right time with the
pandemic but once you know we can go out
there and share these different
perspectives
showing people that might never get a
chance to see this that's really the
whole
mission behind this yeah i was going to
do
this go ahead i just want to say and
and so and also we plan on doing
something about coal country
appalachia the opioid crisis and take
that to liberals
because you know liberals and
progressives also have our blind spots
and our assumptions and our lack of
empathy
as much as we like to fly that that
empathy flag so you know we we're we got
a lot of stories we want to tell
yeah well yeah i was going to say about
you know the interesting thing with
access and vr is that you know not a lot
of people have headsets so you do end up
having
instances where you have to be able to
take vr out into the world and
share it with people and you know let
them sort of try these things on and you
know
i'm kind of curious how you know
obviously the with coronavirus that's
sort of impacted your ability to do that
but is that something that you
definitely want to sort of double down
and commit to once it's possible to
bring these things
out of the world again 100
that's that's our goal i think i mean
and we talked to about the ideas for the
future of this is that we could create
curriculums they could be larger ones
smaller ones they could be ones tailored
for schools
um ones that are put in museums and um
we've even talked about putting this in
a van and being able to drive
cross country and just put it on whoever
we
we see obviously these are all dreams
for for the future not anywhere near
but this is this is about distributing
the technology that we have
using the tools that we have and these
headsets are going to become
we think much more available to people
and it's
i think it's important that this option
is there it's of course going to be used
for many different ways but i think
having this as an option is incredibly
important
yeah um van i'm curious you mentioned in
the video that you
wanted to work with marvel superheroes
and obviously we have a marvel superhero
with us
you know why why was that what were you
kind of looking to do uh
you know with bringing in folks from
from that world into into this one
well well i'm a i'm a
super geek like these are people
including these books behind me are
actually books these are all graphic
novels and stuff like i'm
i would before i was a marvel
comics geek when it was not cool
i was born in 1968 so i i was reading
this stuff
i mean i remember when you had to be a
true true nerd to know the x-men were
to care about the avengers all that sort
of stuff so i grew up with that and
the ethics of you know give me ethics a
lot but that's mean a lot to me
you know stan lee's a vision of people
with having a lot of power having a lot
of responsibility
sticking up for the underdog not giving
up not becoming what you're fighting
villains act a certain way we're not
going to act that way we're going to
have bet we're going to be better
all that stuff went into me very very
deep as a kid
and when i was a little nerd getting you
know bullied and wedgied and pushed
around or whatever
and then all of a sudden i'm six foot
one plus and you know
and then nobody's bullying me anymore i
wanted to use my
law degree and whatever i had to help
people
then suddenly marvel becomes like the
global
like mythology for like you know the
21st century civilization and
and like so you have these actual heroes
have been burned into the minds of like
seven billion people i said geez if
these people actually decide they want
to act heroically
in the rest of the world they can they
can move the whole planet and that's
what we've seen winston duke's
performance uh he was uh um embaco and
the black panther
his performance as a dad in this thing
is unbelievable the first one
brees you know performance and this
thing is unbelievable we've got others
you know josh brolin
uh zoe saldana others who want to come
in and do stuff
listen if if marvel wants to if marvel
heroes or dc heroes
i'm a marvel guy but if dc heroes want
to become heroic
[Music]
yes well you know brie talk a little bit
about that you know where do you see
sort of the overlap with working on a
project like this you know with your
work in film and sort of
being a hero in different ways and in
different formats
sure i'm just always looking for new
ways
to do the right thing um and
this was one of them so my interest in
film was empathy
and for me one of the things that i can
tell
with how far we're going with empathy is
what films people are connecting with
and as we're seeing more diversity on
film it's exciting to me
because i know what the experience is of
watching a movie you're becoming one
with the person on the screen it doesn't
matter how many people
you're watching the thing with it's you
alone
and you are on the edge of your seat
hopefully with
this person you know you are this person
so this is actually taking it a step
further and just saying hey
you're just gonna be dropped into this
body and you're going to experience it
from a first person's perspective so
when i heard about this project it was
so exciting because it's the thing that
i've cared about and wanted to achieve
and i also am very limited in the roles
and stories that i can play because of
my body and so this is a way to
participate
and continue to elevate and create more
dialogue more inclusion
and allow people to have experiences
because that's what this is all about
you know this is what we need is just
more understanding and i know that a lot
of these words are sort of
tired and overused and we're saying
things like this a lot
but it's so true it's so true i mean we
really have
more more that's alike than different
and so much of this of this hatred we
have for one another whatever you
consider the other side
is based on a misunderstanding and i
think this is an incredible way that we
can cut through that and say we're the
same
yeah um well i was just watching i was
re-watching avengers end game the other
day and i realized that captain marvel
is actually kind of an intersectional
feminist when you think about how she
wants to save earth but also every other
galaxy so
um i think that that is very true um
what i'm curious to talk a little bit
about
um the things you have you know kind of
going forward i'm wondering if anything
in
2020 could you know inspire anything in
in the future for something that you
would want to do with
uh with a vr project
you know i wonder
for anybody okay yeah go ahead van
well i mean it's fine you ask i i'm
passionate about the immigration
uh situation uh you know the recent
reporting that
there may be uh uh the enforced
hysterectomies
uh against women in our in refugee camps
and immigration detention
is unbelievable to me um i know zoe
saldana has mentioned that she wants to
do something about immigration
um i i'm passionate about what's going
on in appalachia i'm from you know
tennessee it's not a foreign country to
me
but i haven't thought about the
particularities of 2020 but
um in some ways we were prescient uh
because
uh you know the the situation with
george floyd and the whole black lives
matter uprising
maps right on to what we did with the
first one uh certainly you know time's
up and
and all of that maps on to what we did
with the second one but there'll be many
many more
for me the most important thing i can
say is that
it's okay for us to disagree with each
other that's not a problem we can vote
against each other we can march against
each other
but we need to understand each other
that's the let's if i if
we you and i disagree but i at least
understand where you're coming from
we can still be neighbors we can still
be you know in the same
country together if you are a complete
mystery to me if i have no idea where
the hell you're coming from
and we don't agree we got a problem and
right now technology these algorithms
once once the algorithm knows once your
but your phone knows you're a liberal
is only going to show you liberal
content i promise once they know you're
conservative it's only going to be
conservative and so
you think you're programming your phone
your phone is programming you
and we've got to start using technology
in a different way not because we should
never vote against each other
but because we should never vote against
each other and hate each other and
that's where we're headed right now i'm
very concerned about it
yeah well i think we have time for one
question it wouldn't be wired if i
didn't ask free
do you know what's happening with
captain marvel 2 um are you excited to
get back when do it
oh my god i'm so excited man is so
excited about this question
um i am so excited to talk about that
movie
at a time when marvel's not going to
kill me to talk about it so
i'm going to pivot real quick and say
in response to your question before
there's
infinite stories to tell and we've
talked about
positive stories as well moments of
kindness moments of compassion
um moments of you know when you're
getting help from a stranger
um disability episodes um
i just think that there's just as many
people as there are on the planet
everybody has a story everybody has a
moment that should be shared and
experienced
and so we're excited to collect more and
do more and we hope that the more we
talk about it the more we get it out
there
hopefully there's people out there in
the world that are like that looks cool
we can you know we'll help you because
that's that's what we need right now we
just need help to keep pushing the
project forward
perfect well thank you so much for
joining us i really
really love this conversation and thank
you for coming to wired25
uh yeah have a wonderful day thanks
everybody thank you so much
see you later bye
well that was a fabulous day and it
ended on
just the right note and it was an
extraordinary set of conversations that
were linked to what linked together in
ways that
surprised me and probably struck all of
you while you we watched
there was i thought a theme of people
kind of going outside the boundaries
what you might expect them to do whether
it's as a ux designer or
as a chef or as a filmmaker and looking
at broader questions in society and then
using one's role
in that position to do something bigger
and of course the big theme of the day
something van jones brought up at the
end of that conversation which is
empathy
and that was the core of reed hastings
in our conversation about
how netflix works across cultures and
what the point
of netflix is right is what the ghetto
gastro people were talking about as we
talk about the
importance of understanding food
understanding the people who make it
understanding
what it means it's how we think about
how horror films can help us see
people we may not see understand people
in ways we may not
have understood and so that's the real
theme of today how empathy can help us
connect understand and get
closer to each other in a world that
sometimes pulls us apart
so thank you so much for sticking
through it
thank you to all of our fabulous
moderators
all of our superheroes who attended
everybody who put it together
thank you to samsung thank you to vonage
for supporting this
and very importantly remember this is
not the end of wire25 it is day one and
we're gonna be going on for the next two
weeks
the next one will be wednesday september
23rd
at noon eastern 9 a.m pacific
we'll be talking again about some of the
intense issues in our society we will
have
a segment we're putting together on the
fires sweeping the west
dee and steve allen and isla meyer smith
scientists documenting the climate
crisis will be there
sarah fryer the ceo of next door a key
shelter in place lifeline during the
pandemic will be talking with us
as will arlen hamilton and katie ray in
both venture capitals and
venture capitalists investing in under
underrepresented entrepreneurs
capital intensive tough tech which is
problems that are
really important and hard to solve and
that maria
she's the ceo and executive editor of
the news site the rappler and
a hero a lot of us in journalism for
standing up to
authoritarianism and reminding us
why her profession our profession
matters so much for the world
after all those talks we're going to do
some deeper dives with the speakers
you'll have meetups after the program
at 1 45 pm eastern so stay tuned for
those they'll be announced on monday
registered attendees will be able to
pick the ones they want to go to
so thank you thank you for coming to our
first virtual wire25 it was an
experiment for us for you
but i loved it and i hope you did too
see you at the next one
[Music]
you